la construcción del tren Maya Abre cada
vez más polémicas se trata de uno de los
proyectos del presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador que busca promover
el turismo en la Península de Yucatán en
el sureste del país lo que se va a
buscar Precisamente es que la gente que
llega a Cancún 30 millones de visitantes
en vez de que se queden nada más en
Cancún o que lleguen hasta Playa del
Carmen puedan
internarse en todo Quintana Roo el
ambicioso proyecto que costará unos 20
mil millones de dólares enciende las
alarmas de múltiples organizaciones
ambientalistas su construcción aseguran
dividirá parte de la selva mexicana
generando un enorme perjuicio para las
especies que viven en dichos ecosistemas
como los jaguares a causaron un efecto
Barrera que interrumpe la conectividad o
el corredor biológico por donde se
desplazan estas especies Así que muy
importante mantener esos corredores
biológicos y queremos tener a la especie
en un futuro aquí en nuestro país
el gobierno mexicano Espera que la
construcción finalice Este 2023 pero
expertos alertan que los efectos ya se
están sintiendo sobre todo en las cuevas
subterráneas típicas de la región que
retienen agua potable y ahora lo que
estamos registrando en este día que ya
hace unas semanas se metieron unos
barrenos de exploración y donde arriba
ya están metiendo pilotes para sostener
el tren acá lo que estamos viendo Es que
ya hay este material de construcción que
no pertenece a la cueva los riesgos
ambientales contrastan con las cifras
que según fonatur la agencia encargada
del proyecto generará el tren según sus
cálculos para 2030 podría sacar a más de
un millón de personas de la pobreza y
crear hasta 715.000 nuevos empleos